So its been basically two weeks since I pulled
my SIM from my XS Max and made the S10+ my
main device in an attempt to see how much
greener the grass is on the other side, and
let me tell you it definitely is in a lot
of ways, but it’s patchy.
I’m working on my full detailed review of
the S10+ from an iPhone users perspective
so make sure to subscribe and enable notifications
so you don’t miss out, but for now, here
are the biggest things that stuck out to me
so far.
First off, Face ID is amazing.
I mean I knew that before, but its definitely
much easier to use in the real world.
The ultrasonic sensor is very cool, and its
really secure which you’ll know if you checked
out our fingerprint hack video, but man is
it flakey even after adding my thumb a second
time and trying intentionally lean and improve
how I use it.
Face ID is effortless, fairly quick, and works
in apps without needing to do anything.
Now above that ultrasonic sensor is the best
smartphone display I’ve ever put my eyes
on.
In our unboxing comparison, it didn’t seem
as bright as the XS Max, but in the real world
once adaptive brightness learns that you like
it turned up high it does seem brighter in
direct sunlight.
Along with that its definitely more detailed
in its high rez setting, and watching movies
with it is fantastic, especially in HDR.
Now the iPhone isn’t bad by any means, but
you do notice a difference switching back
to it, Especially if you’re streaming in
1440P on the Samsung.
The speakers are really loud.
After a lot of use, I don’t think they sound
as good as the iPhone, but I would take that
trade-off because when you’re in a loud
environment or watching a quiet video it really
helps.
The battery powering that gorgeous display
is over 25% larger than the one in my XS Max,
but does it help in real-world use?
Honestly, I’m not too sure.
Both of them last a full day of heavy use
but are close to dead when I go to plug them
in for the night.
I’ll take a closer look at this in my full
review.
One thing I had to change icon packs since
they are very cartoony in my opinion.
I also hated the way the keyboard worked and
I swapped it for the swift keyboard.
I remember hearing that Apple went through
a ton of on-screen keyboard prototypes before
Steve was happy and I could I remember that
being a big thing I noticed when I bought
my first iPhone, the 6 Plus.
In general, you have a ton of customization
and options, but it takes more effort and
overall I’m happy with how my iPhone works
well and gets out of the way.
One thing that I’m not happy about is features
that are completely excluded in iOS as I saw
in multiple apps, the biggest one probably
being Youtubes the picture in picture mode
which is awesome for multitasking.
I love and hate the notifications.
On one end the S10+ and android provide much
greater looking notifications with more info
like thumbnails for youtube videos.
If you Chromecast content you get constant
controls in the notifications and in general
I love having the notification bar at the
top of the phone like all android phones offer.
When I get an important e-mail or text, the
icon will stay at the top until I deal with
it.
This is way better for me than what iOS offers
since I'm often doing something and can’t
respond right away, but then later I just
forget about it.
It doesn’t look as clean, but at a quick
glance I can see if I’m in the silent mode,
if my alarm is on, and other icons.
Along with that, I like the always on display,
and really wish Apple would include it since
their flagships now use OLED displays.
Along with those notifications differences,
we also get a lot more annoying ones that
I wasn’t used to with iOS.
System notifications, downloads, and just
plain ads for apps I didn’t download like
Spotify.
Amazon is suggesting products I should buy,
Modern combat needs reinforcements and Asphalt
9 just refueled my car lol.
You can disable notifications for apps but
these are the thing I just didn’t need to
deal with before.
Now let’s talk about the cameras.
I LOVE the wide-angle lens.
I didn’t use it that often, but when you
need its great to have and you can also get
some cool perspectives.
The photos hve more contrast and saturation
than iPhones which is great if you don’t
like to edit.
One big difference between the two is portrait
mode being wide compared to telephoto, and
there are plusses for both so I wish both
would give us the option to choose which lens
we wan to use.
Samsung has made major strides in terms of
image quality and it shows.
The only downside about the S10’s camera
is the shutter lag.
While it does mean the images have less noise
since I often found myself missing shots of
my kids since it takes the actual photo about
noticeably after you press the shutter.
The iPhone feels like a powerful phone for
minimalists.
It just works.
Yes, you have much less customization and
features, much fewer options when your taking
photos, and everything is much cleaner at
the expense of better notifications but it
just works and is less frustrating.
If you own other Apple products the iPhone
is an even better device with continuity,
airplay, airdrop, etc.
This has been the case for years but what
wasn’t always been the case was the hardware
quality both the materials and feel and other
things like camera and sound quality.
My iPhone used to be ahead in many ways but
with the Galaxy S10 series, I feel like this
is the first time I can say that the hardware
is actually better overall.
Thank you guys for watching my 2-week real
world comparison between the devices.
If you have any questions go ahead and ask
in the comments section below and I’ll try
to cover them in my full detailed review of
the Galaxy S10+ and if you want to check that
out go ahead and subscribe by clicking right
up there.
This has been Max with Max tech and I’ll
see you in the next video.